♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN
MAKING HISTORY BUT NOT IN A GOOD
WAY.
SURGING GAS PRICES AND HIGHER
RENT PUSHING INFLATION TO A 40
YEAR HIGH.
PRICES ARE UP 8.5% JUST FROM A
YEAR AGO MAKING IT THE FASTEST
SPIKE IN MORE THAN FOUR DECADES.
AS USUAL, HERE IS THE PRESIDENT
TRYING TO PIN THE BLAME ON VLAD.
>> PUTIN'S INVASION OF UKRAINE
HAS DRIVEN UP PRICES ALL OVER
THE WORLD.
70% OF THE INCREASE IN PRICES IN
MARCH CAME FROM PUTIN'S PRICE
HIKE.
DOING EVERYTHING I CAN TO BRING
DOWN THE PRICES OF THE PUTIN
PRICE HIKE.
WE HAVE MADE PROGRESS SINCE THE
MARCH INFLATION DATA.
YOUR FAMILY BUDGET, YOUR ABILITY
TO FILL UP YOUR TANK SHOULD NOT
HINGE ON WHETHER A DICTATOR
COMMITS WAR AND COMMITS GENOCIDE
HALF A WORLD AWAY.
>> Jesse: NICE TRY, JOE.
THE NUMBERS TELL A VERY
DIFFERENT STORY.
PRICES HAVE BEEN ON THE RISE
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE, LONG BEFORE PUTIN
LAUNCHED AN INVASION.
EVEN THE LEFT-WING MEDIA DOESN'T
BUY IT.
>> THIS WHOLE IDEA, THE
WHITE HOUSE IS JUST LOSING THE
MESSAGING WAR.
IF ONLY THEY KNEW HOW GOOD THE
JOB SITUATION WAS.
IF YOU ASK AMERICANS WHY DO YOU
THINK THE ECONOMY IS BAD, IT'S
INFLATION.
THE VOTERS KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING ON.
THEY ARE NOT STUPID.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT STUPID,
DANA.
>> Dana: THE PUTIN PRICE HIKE.
WHEN SOMEBODY TRIES TOO HARD.
>> Jesse: DON'T I KNOW IT.
>> Dana: YOU CRINGE.
[LAUGHTER]
I FEEL LIKE THE PUTIN PRICE
HIKE.
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEY KNOW PRICES HAVE BEEN GOING
UP FOR A LONG TIME.
THEY CAN APPRECIATE THERE WAS A
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS BUT THEY
ALSO KNOW WHAT HAVE BEEN ON
PRICES AS WELL.
THE DARLING OF THE MIDTERM
ELECTION ADS IS NOT GOING TO BE
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
NANCY PELOSI.
IT'S GOING TO BE THESE OBAMA
ECONOMISTS WHO ARE COMING OUT
AND SAYING THE OBAMA ALUMS
RUNNING THE ECONOMY FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE IT ALL
WRONG.
THOSE ADS CUT THEMSELVES RIGHT
NOW HOME HAVE YOU NOTICED THE
MEDIA IS TRYING TO HELP THE
DEMOCRATS SO MUCH.
MIDTERM IS GOING TO BE BAD.
DEMOCRATS BETTER PAY ATTENTION.
EVEN WORSE THAN THEY THINK AND
YOU SEE IT EVERYWHERE.
SENDING SIGNALS LIKE YOU'VE GOT
TO DO MORE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE PUTIN
PRICE HIKE IS GOING TO CUT IT.
>> Jesse: IS IT GOING TO CUT
IT OR DO THEY NEED TO CHANGE THE
MESSAGE?
>> Harold: NO DOUBT THAT THE
POLLING DATA WE'VE SEEN,
INFLATION IS WHAT BUSINESS
LEADERS FROM ALL THE POLLING
DATA, WHEN YOU THINK IT'S
INFLATION.
IT'S WHAT PEOPLE BELIEVE AND YOU
CAN'T FIGHT THAT.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
THEY DO HAVE TO TELL A BETTER
STORY BUT THEY HAVE TO TELL A
BETTER STORY WITH ANSWERS.
MY INTRODUCTION TO POLITICS AND
ORGANIZATION, THE HOOPLA AND THE
NOISE, YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE PEOPLE
DOING IT.
THEN YOU FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
SOUGHT.
IF I'M IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
AS YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING OUT FOR
A FEW WEEKS, THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THE COUNTRY APPROPRIATED TO DEAL
WITH COVID.
TO STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT, GAS
PRICES.
THERE IS NO DOUBT WHEN YOU
IMPOSE SANCTIONS ON A HUGE
PRODUCER OF GAS AND OIL,
WHATEVER THE THING IS, IT'S
GOING TO CAUSE PRICES TO GO UP.
THE BIGGEST PRODUCERS OF WHEAT.
THINGS ARE GOING TO GO UP OF
THEIR SANCTIONS ON THE COUNTRY.
SHANGHAI SHUT DOWN BECAUSE OF
COVID.
WE CAN QUARREL WHETHER SHANGHAI
SHOULD'VE DONE THAT BUT THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENING.
>> Jesse: SO YOU ARE SAYING
BLAME CHINA INSTEAD OF RUSSIA?
>> Harold: I HAVE BEING A
REALIST.
WE ALL KNOW.
HE NOT THE FIRST PRESIDENT TO
PLAY POLITICS.
ALL POLITICIANS PLAY POLITICS.
THE BEST ONES WIN ADDED.
HE'S NOT WINNING THIS ARGUMENT
RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD REPURPOSE MONEY SPENT
FOR COVID TO HELP SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE AND MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILIES, I WOULD TIGHTEN THE
THRESHOLDS OF THE QUALIFICATIONS
TO ENSURE THAT YOU'VE GOT ONE
PERSON FOCUSING.
YOU KNOW WHO THAT IS?
JOE MANCHIN.
HAVE THEM AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU WANT TO BE NUMBER ONE JOE
AND ME NEVER TO JOE, I ACCEPT
THAT BUT I WANT THE BEST
INTEREST FOR WEST VIRGINIANS AND
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
SHORT OF DOING THAT, DEMOCRATS
OR CONTINUE TO FACE POOLS LIKE
THAT.
I'M A DEMOCRAT.
WE CAN FIND OURSELVES IN A
REALLY BAD ELECTORAL POSITION
COME NOVEMBER.
>> Jesse: DO YOU FEEL PROUD
WHEN YOU SAY YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT?
>> Harold: I DO.
>> Jesse: JUDGE JEANINE,
YOU'RE TAPPING, TAPPING.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE'S THE
BOTTOM LINE.
JOE BIDEN CAN'T GET OUT OF HIS
OWN WAY.
YOU THINK JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO
CHANGE THE MESSAGE?
IT'S ALL ABOUT PUTIN.
ALL ABOUT PUTIN.
THAT'S ALL HE KNOWS HOW TO SAY
THAT AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMARTER
THAN THAT.
THEY SAW GAS PRICES GO UP BEFORE
PUTIN.
A LOT OF THE SANCTIONS DON'T GO
INTO EFFECT UNTIL JUNE 24.
WHO ARE WE KIDDING?
JOE IS GOING TO MAKE SURE TO
SUSPEND THE BANDANNA ON HIGHER
ETHANOL GASOLINE TO LOWER PRICES
WHICH AMOUNTS TO A PENNY ON THE
GALLON.
THAT'S HIS RESOLUTION.
JOE BIDEN DESERVES WHAT HE IS
GETTING.
HE HAS BEEN SO WOKE AND SO
FOCUSED ON THE LEFT THAT HE
HASN'T BEEN LISTENING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HOW COULD HE LISTEN TO THE
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
THE PROBLEM HERE GOING FORWARD
IS HE'S BRINGING EVERYONE DOWN
WITH HIM.
SINCE APRIL.
HE DOESN'T HAVE THE TIME TO DO
IT.
HE WAS RUNNING TO IOWA TODAY.
THE FRONT RUNNER IN IOWA DIDN'T
MANAGE TO GET THE NUMBERS TO
QUALIFY FOR THE PRIMARY THAT IS
THE GUY HE IS SUPPORTING?
THE WHOLE THING IS A MESS.
WHEN IT'S YOUR FAULT, TAKE THE
BURDEN THEN DEAL WITH IT.
HE CAN'T BECAUSE HE'S
INCOMPETENT.
>> Jesse: THE JUDGE MAKES A
GOOD POINT.
IF YOU JUST LISTEN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE SPRING,
SUMMER, FALL.
PEOPLE WERE GETTING UPSET ABOUT
INFLATION.
INCIDENT LISTENING TO HIS
ADVISORS WHO ARE SAYING IT WILL
GO AWAY.
HE MIGHT'VE BEEN AHEAD OF THIS.
>> Greg: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LISTEN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHEN YOU HAVE POLLSTERS.
NO PROBLEM EXISTS UNTIL THE
POLLSTER TELLS YOU IT EXISTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S WORSE.
HAVING CNN POOP ON YOU OR A
BIRD?
HE SAW A BIG PILE OF BIRD CRAP
ON BIDEN'S SHOULDER FOLLOWED BY
CNN.
I COULD TELL WHICH WAS MORE
DAMAGING.
I KNOW HAROLD, WHEN YOU SAY PLAY
POLITICS, IT'S A NICE WASTING
LINE THROUGH YOUR TEETH.
THE PUTIN PRICE HIKE IS A LIE.
IT'S A LIE.
IT'S AN EFFORT INSTEAD OF
SOLVING THE ACTUAL SUFFERING,
SOLVING THE MESSAGING.
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
OVERKILL.
THEY ARE TACKLING THE MESSAGING
FIRST RATHER THAN THE ACTUAL
PROBLEM AND THAT'S WHAT REALLY
PISSES PEOPLE OFF.
WHY DO WE HAVE INFLATION, CRIME,
HOMELESSNESS, SO MUCH MENTAL
ILLNESS, SO MUCH MALAISE?
IT'S ABOUT THE MESSAGING AND NOT
THE SUFFERING.
WHY DO DEMOCRATS, PROGRESSIVES,
REALLY NEED PLACES LIKE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND TO A
LARGER EXTENT TWITTER?
WHY DO THEY NEED TWITTER IN
THEIR POCKET?
THE KEY TO THEIR SURVIVAL
BECAUSE IN TERMS OF PRESERVING
THEIR POWER, YOU HAVE TO HIDE
THEIR OUTCOMES, THE
CONSEQUENCES, THE RESULTS OF
THEIR POLICIES.
THINK OF HOW THE MEDIA WAS ABLE
TO COVER FOR THE RIOTS, THE
HUNTER LAPTOP, MENTAL ILLNESS
WHICH IS RAGING ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND IT'S GOTTEN WORSE.
IT'S BECAUSE THE MEDIA HELPS
COVER IT UP.
SO YOU DON'T SEE THESE OUTCOMES.
THE PROBLEM WITH INFLATION, YOU
CAN SEE THE OUTCOMES.
YOU JUST WALK INTO THE
SUPERMARKET AND YOU LOOK AT A
HALF A POUND OF STEAK.
IT'S NOW MORE THAN A POUND OF
STEAK WAS TWO MONTHS AGO.
THIS SOMETHING YOU CAN'T HIDE.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE GOING TO
LOSE.
IF THE RED WAVE ISN'T LIKE A RED
WEDDING, THERE'S NO HOPE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
EVERYBODY SHOULD WIN EVEN IF
THEY HAVE BAD CANDIDATES.
EVEN IF THEY HAVE BAD, WACKY
CANDIDATES.
>> Jesse: THE WACKIEST
CANDIDATES TO WIN.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING BIDEN
CAN DO THAT WOULD BE MORE
BELIEVABLE.
>> Jesse: EVERY SINGLE DAY OF
THE WEEK.
POWELL SHOULD'VE RAISED RATES
LAST YEAR.
>> Harold: THE BIRD POOP, THAT
MEANS HE'S IN FOR SOME GOOD
LUCK.
>> Greg: LANDED ON H